BENJAMIN NETANYAHU TO RECALL THE
AMBASSADOR TO POLAND IN PROTEST.
>> Bret: DAVID LEE MILLER,
THANK YOU.
WE ARE EIGHT DAYS FROM THE START
OF THE WINTER OLYMPICS IN
SOUTH KOREA.
SOME BIG MOVEMENT TODAY ON TWO
FRANCE.
RUSSIA MAY BE GETTING SOME OF
ITS BAND ATHLETES BACK IN
HEAVILY PROTECTED BORDERS.
SENIOR FOREIGN AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT GREG PALKOT HAS
THE STORY.
>> ...
DIPLOMACY ON THE PENINSULA.
AHEAD OF NEXT WEEK'S TOUR
OLYMPICS.
SKIERS, SKATERS AND OTHERS
PARTICIPATING WITH THOSE FROM
THE SOUTH ALONG WITH JOINT
CULTURAL EVENTS, THE AIM IS TO
IMPROVE TENSE RELATIONS BETWEEN
THE COUNTRIES.
STICK WITH THE OPENING CEREMONY
WILL STAGE IN THE TRADITIONAL
BUT ALSO THAT OF MODERN CULTUREO
BUT ALSO THAT OF MODERN CULTUREF
SOUTH KOREA AS WELL AS
PERFORMANCES INTEGRATING BOTH
CULTURES.
>> NORTH KOREA HAS CANCELED ONE
EVENT NORTH OF THE DMZ, AND
THERE ARE REPORTS KIM JONG UN
REGIME WILL STAGE A MILITARY.
IN PYONGYANG JUST BEFORE THE
OPENING CEREMONY.
IT COULD FEATURE MISSILES NOW
THREATENING THE U.S.
WASHINGTON SUPPORTS THE OUTRAGE,
BY ALL OPTIONS, I THINK YOU HAVE
TO SAY IT WILL COME IT HAS TO
INCLUDE MILITARY OPTIONS.
>> THERE COULD BE OTHER
POLITICAL POINTS.
DOPING BANDS REVERSED.
INTERNATIONAL OLYMPIC COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE'S SAY THEY CAN'T
NECESSARILY JOIN OTHER RUSSIAN
ATHLETES ARE THAT IT WILL
RESTORE RUSSIA'S REPUTATION.
>> SINCE THE COMMITTEE HAS
SUSPENDED, RUSSIAN ATHLETES CAN
PARTICIPATE IN FORFEITING
-- >> SOME OF YOUR NORTH KOREA
MIGHT RESTART SOME OF ITS